>> Opposers this can't wait.
Everyone's talking
about this royal wedding
between Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle.
But not me.
I don't need to look across
the pond for entertainment.
Believe me I've tried.
The pond is just an entire
fucking ocean.
Misleading.
We don't need Prince Harry.
No we have our old favorite
royal son. Jared Kushner
and he's way better than
Harry in every single way.
I mean listen to Harry speak.
>> I Managed to persuade him
to come and join me.
>> We camped out with each
under the stars
Ugh. Nails on a chalkboard
right.
Jared on the other hand.
My name is Jared Kushner.
Pure butter.
And what does Harry even do.
Oh that's right. Nothing.
Jared meanwhile is in charge
of peace in the Middle East.
And last I checked.
Mission accomplished.
Harry lives at the castle.
Meanwhile Jared has
a skyscraper in Manhattan
that no one will buy.
You do the math.
And as for Meghan Markle
what she famous for the TV
show suits the USA Network.
Ah well our princess Ivanka
makes suits by the China network
and they hold up
pretty well the first three
or four times
you wear them. Case closed.
So yeah enjoy the royal wedding.
I'll be hate tweeting
about her dress.
Jesus.
Stunning.
>> How is it both modern and
traditional at the same time.
America first.